ne parlez pas de confinement mais plutôt
de nouvelles mesures de freinage
supplémentaires ce terme un peu
technocratique il est signé emmanuel
macron déclarations faites à des
journalistes en marge d'une rencontre à
l'elysée lors de la journée à de la
francophonie déclaration qui vient aussi
contredire les propos tenus par jean
castex lors de sa dernière conférence de
presse jeudi dernier
alors si ce premier week-end de
printemps a été marqué donc par de
nouvelles restrictions il l'a aussi été
par quelques couacs de la part du
gouvernement tout d'abord sur
l'attestation qui devait faire son grand
retour le gouvernement a finalement
renoncé face aux critiques et aux
moqueries
pas moins de 15 motifs de sorties et des
règles jugé illisible alors l'opposition
évidemment s'en est donné à coeur joie
qualifiant cette attestation de
chefs-d'oeuvre bureaucratique chez les
républicains par exemple ou de symboles
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire par
le gouvernement du côté de la france
insoumise dorénavant les français vivant
dans les départements concernés par ces
mesures peuvent sortir avec seulement un
justificatif de domicile avant le
couvre-feu instauré à 19h et dans la
limite d'un périmètre de 10 km autour de
leur domicile et situation confuse aussi
autour à des invitations à domicile le
porte parole du gouvernement a été sans
ambiguïté vous ne pouvez pas inviter
chez vous des personnes pour un dîner
elle ni pour un déjeuner at il est
déclaré des propos qui ont poussé le
ministère de l'intérieur à une petite
précision auprès de nos confrères de bfm
tv
il s'agissait d'une recommandation et
non d'une interdiction les
verbalisations ne sont possibles qu'en
cas de fêtes clandestines où deux êtres
tapage nocturne alors concrètement
comment les français ont-ils perçu ce
nouveau tueur de vieilles tours de vis
et ces témoignages au micro de nicolas
coupé je n'ai aucun jugement trop
stricte ou pas assez stricte
factuellement ça nous rajoute à ça nous
donne juste une heure de plus
mais ça change rien à notre quotidien en
fait ni avant ni après la preuve c'est
que on s'est tous regardé un match bon
bah du coup on a gagné une heure de
cours sincèrement c'est pas un
confinement puisqu'on est dehors et qui
a pas de problème
simplement je pense que il y avait
vraiment une compréhension psychologique
de l'état d'esprit de la plupart des
français pensent qu'un peu une dictature
sanitaire quoi c'est tout tout tout au
nom des deux fois la barre du duc ovide
vont se retrouvent s'occuper d'eux des
jeunes surtout ceux qui fait les
commerçants c'est ce qui fait de voila
quoi me dérange un peu parce que pour
moi c'est par un continent parce que il
ya tout le monde dans la rue non ça
changerait l'âme au quotidien il ya pas
grand chose qui change c'est même encore
mieux le soir pour sortir du skate 19
heures donc non pas de changement outre
ces seize départements de nouveaux
territoires pourraient être concernés
par ces restrictions dans les 15 jours
ou trois semaines à venir déclarations
dans les colonnes du quotidien nice
matin d' olivier guérin médecins et
nouveau membre du conseil scientifique